hello and welcome to this video playing
for G Becky knows and played him played
him recently don't quite remember what
that game was okay I was that porn
Avalanche game I had white then keep
forgetting stuff this is how I play it
him
okay and it had to happen at some point
yeah mate we should see what is really
funny move he says well played yeah it's
a good good sense of humor I don't know
yeah what can you say about this game I
was still um it is short who would still
put it on yeah so this is the line that
I had on the board a couple of times
already in in the videos white um has to
take on d6 this is what you need to do
and now the normal move is a form quite
logical and here I'm going b5 this is
what I remember
b5 it grabs a bit of space and allows
the Bishop d7 continuation later it is
some this is a very complicated blood if
I remember correctly yeah there is the
caption which is very very cool
Jake's v5 then check check something
like that is a line I don't quite read
this on the board 92 and 95 yeah it's
very complicated I had this in my banker
repertoire accessible but you know if
you don't get it on the board you tend
to forget it and I don't repeat my my
openings that much will definitely be
useful to do a repetition there once in
a while yeah one thing that doesn't work
is the retreat and this is so mate like
in the game funny
yeah this is a good line by the way
against the Trump if you look for
something sharp c5 fits the bill
yeah what can take or play d5 most
people play d5 after which this Knight
e4 is quite okay I believe
and if they take I'll take with the G
pawn and here
think I go we should just know like or
d6o Bishop g7 Bishop g7 f5 some
something like that I play again mm-hmm
it's been a while okay guys thanks for
watching this very short video